hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled detection of chemical agents in
bone
by lcms i'm susie valdez of lab roots
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by agilent
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
click on the ask a question box located
on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational
and offers free continuing education
credits click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right corner of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit
without further ado i now present
today's speaker
dr timothy garrett an associate
professor
at university of florida for a complete
biography on dr garrett
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr garrett you may now begin your
presentation
welcome sir
well thank you for that introduction and
thank you for the opportunity to be here
to talk to you all about some research
that we did at the university of florida
uh in the detection of chemical agents
in bone
by lc mass spectrometry i want to point
out that
this work was was done by dr katie rubin
as part of her graduate work here at the
university of florida and she led
all these efforts in a lot of the method
development was done
in collaboration with both forensic
toxicology
and forensic anthropology and pathology
so
so hopefully i'll give you a good
overview of what your what were
what we worked on and the problems
behind uh
the problems and needs behind chemical
detection in bone
so overall the problem exists
that there is a need uh in toxicology
for the analysis of both
primarily what most determinations of
cause of death are determined by
uh skeletal remains and they're usually
using physical trauma or other
other signs that can show what might
have happened during death
but there are often new cases showing up
that have no physical signs of death
and thus no way to ascertain what
happens in those skeletal remains
so and analysis of bone is routinely
done
in a toxicology lab and so often
forensic toxicologists might bring in a
forensic anthropologist
to help understand what might have
happened to this individual but there's
just so limited information that we can
gather without digging deeper into the
chemicals
there have been a new set of studies
that have come out more recently
that have started to look at whether or
not we can measure chemicals and bones
but more experimentation is needed and
more and more validation
there's still some issues whether or not
the interoper inter
operability of the skeletal toxicology
and what it means when chemicals are
present or not present in bone there's
still a lot of
concerns about how that might show up
and and how do we interpret these
results
because uh whether they're present or
not may or may not have caused death so
we have to understand
what what their presence means in terms
of other studies
so some of the questions that we have in
this study are how does xenobiotics
uh forensic and clinical interest
interact with bone
uh basic questions and we also are
interested in
how nerve agents uh could be isolated
and detected from the bone matrix
and we're also interested whether or not
nerve agents would be absorbed
onto the bone in vivo and so we want to
design experiments to do this kind of
work
it has been shown in the past that drugs
and drug metabolites can be detected
from
fresh bone and they've been reliably
detected
up to at least 15 years after death as
well
one of some of the issues that have been
shown is that most of the exposure is
really
concerned considering more acute versus
chronic and so if you have higher levels
of in this case ketamine that was found
higher levels of an acute toxicity
versus a chronic
chronic use so that tells us a little
bit about what might have happened so
that does give us
a little bit about dose depth interval
and how important that might be
and then there's also differences
between a type of bone within an
individual versus trabecular or cortex
that might tell us where the best sample
to get the right kind of information
and overall the best responses have been
seen using trabecular bone
such as vertebrae or elements of the
pelvic area
so let's talk a little bit about bone
chemistry so bone chemistry is important
of course to understand the chemical
manifestations of what happens so
bone consists of an organic matrix
that's approximately 35
solid mass and most of that is 90
collagen
they also consist of an inorganic matrix
that consists of about 65 percent
roughly of the mass and that contains
phosphorus
hydroxyapatite as well as carbonated
calcium and the carbon present
increases the solubility and the
substitution within the bone matrix
there's of course also water present as
part of the mass
and it consists in two layers it
consists as a bulk
as well as a hydrated layer right and so
the bulk layer provides a solvent for
diffusion
into the into the matrix into the bone
as well as transporting ions to and from
the osteocytes during mineralization
while the hydrated layer is a structured
surface layer that surrounds the bone
crystals and constitutes a
non-hepatic domain of the inorganic
matrix
and it's thought that there's an
exchangeable mineral as a part of this
hydrated layer but of course more
research needs to be done
in that but basically we have a way to
bring ions in and we have afraid to
bring ions out through this
this process
if you want to learn more about the this
this research uh katie rubin wrote a
rece
review recent review article discussing
the the state and future of skeletal
toxicology
both from a humanitarian and a forensic
approach to help understand where and
how this would be important in the
future
so getting back to the model ions
we have a mechanism by which ions can
diffuse
into the matrix uh and there's a
gradient that exists
inside this inside the bone
and so we have an exchangeable ability
to move ions in and move ions out from
the serum
and from as drugs go in so drugs that
are ionized
by body temperature and physiological ph
are most likely to be exchangeable
and even even ions with potentially low
in affinity for bone may be exchangeable
as well
because of their ionic ionic ability and
their ionic charge to get into the
hydrated layer
there's also been studies that have
shown that
the type of fluid makes a difference as
well as the exchange
between iron replacement in and out of
the in and out of the bone
and one thing to note
is that this can happen with multiple
kinds of
species and multiple kinds of drugs that
have happened in the past
this has been seen with uh drugs of
abuse with
uh like opioids and it's also been used
in
uh other other kinds of uh normal drugs
that are taken
in a normal situation
and so drug ions that are good
substitutes
uh or attracted to the bone minerals may
absorb into the
hard surface of the into the heart
surface of the bone into the crystal
structure and those ions may or may not
be freely exchangeable
but they can be just they can they can
fall out
drugs may also indirectly absorb to the
surface if they are complex to other
compounds that that are
likely to be absorbed so if they form a
complex they might be able to get in
to that bone structure if the bone
surface is
modeling or remodeling absorbed ions
also could be trapped
permanently into the bone matrix and
this is where we're interested in this
kind of concept for forensic
analysis that these trapped trapped
species
would wouldn't get removed in the
absence of resorption so they would stay
in there for a long period of time
allowing us to potentially measure what
may or may not be present
in the skeletal remains and so what we
find is that most drugs of forensic
interest
are exchangeable but there's are a
select tox set of toxic substances that
could make them good substitutes for
this mineral lattice mean rendering them
fully incorporated into the bone and not
being pulled out or not being
exchangeable over a period of time
a class of compounds that's likely to do
this are organophosphates
organophosphates represent pesticides as
well as chemical nerve agents
pesticides of course result in several
deaths worldwide every year
up front approximately 250 000 and
chemical weapons have been used for
over the years of course they were just
developed for
military militaristic purposes and
they've been used in different attacks
throughout the years including
iraq syria and japan and so
if we look a little bit of the structure
of these we have structures based on
what could be present
in the bone hydrox hydrogen phosphate is
found in the
hydrated layer of the bone and and so
if we look more detailed in the
structure mpa which is a common
metabolite of many nerve agents
has a very similar structure with only a
methyl group
different between hydroxya hydrogen
phosphate which
could lend itself to being incorporated
into the into the matrix
and so we also have empa impa pmp
and cmpa uh there are other agents from
either vx sarin
or other types of nerve agents that have
a similar phosphate structure which
again could lead to lend themselves to
be incorporated into bone
and thus allow us to detect them later
on in life
to know what might may or may not have
happened to the same individual
we also have uh the pyrophosphate so
pyrophosphate is one of the most common
uh species in the in
in the bone and a bone seeking compound
and then we also have tep which is
triacyl pyrophosphate
and so you can sort of see that
similarity with that organic pesticide
where its structure is very similar to
that of
pyrophosphate and there's also a drug
that's used to treat osteoporosis
childrenic acid which is a
bisphosphonate and also could be bone
seeking and so these
are just a select few of other potential
species that are present that we either
might take for for a clinical reason as
in osteoporosis
or that might be present in other re
other regions for us to understand what
happens to the bone and how we can
analyze
specific species present in the bone
later on in life
so in general uh phosphates will will be
strong curators
and they look they should absorb
strongly to mineral surfaces including
these hydroxyapatites
and of course calcium present uh
increases this ability to
uh to absorb and there's also been shown
that mpa has already
formed a strong complex with calcium
and so there's just there's a a reason
that we could
have behind this and why bone would be
an important and y bone would be a
realistic matrix to go and look for
these chemicals
to help understand what might have
happened during a chemical exposure
and so these are these are the chemical
target species that we're interested in
for this
this study primarily and you can most of
them
are negative ions because of the
phosphate structures so they'll be
ionized into negative ion mode
and they're all metabolites of these
various gases that have been used in the
past
so to do this work we centered on the
use of liquid chromatography mass
spectrometry in particular using high
resolution mass spectrometry as a
starting point
and we the reason we use high resolution
as the method development
approach is several reasons one it
allows us to measure
our our metabolites and our target
species of interest using
accurate mass and using the mass
resolution capable on this instrument
and it also allows us to see other
species that are present and during
method development you have
do you have to understand the matrix and
what what is present in the matrix and
how that might
affect your your ion suppression or
might affect
any other issues relating to how you can
analyze your species and having
an ability to use a high resolution
platform to do that might allow us to
identify other metabolites that could be
interfering with our method
so that we could go back and try to pull
those metabolites out with it
either by modifying the extraction mode
or by modifying the chromatography to
help
reduce that kind of background and you
might not get that if you go directly to
a triple quad
because the triple quad will only let
you look at what you're looking at
which is which is one of the reasons why
it's an amazing instrument but
in this case starting from a an unusual
matrix that not many
individuals have tested before using a
an
instrument that's capable of multi
measuring more ions at the same time i
think
is highly valuable and so this is this
is where we started and after we
developed the method in the qtof we
moved we moved it to a triple quad and
made a
a selected reaction monitoring method
for the quantitative performance of this
assay
so it's sort of starting in a two-phase
approach to do method development
optimization and then targeted
quantitation without having to do all
that in
on one instrument
with any kind of chromatographic
approach there are often multiple ways
of course to start and do separation
reverse phase chromatography or rpc is
one of the most common approaches where
you use an aqueous
mobile phase typically water and you
have a non-polar stationary phase like a
column that's a c18 column or a c8
column
and then you increase your organic
gradient maybe methanol or maybe
acetonitrile
to elute the species of interest no of
course the loot based on hydrophobicity
and so the hydrophobic species will be
retained on the column while the
hydrophilic species will be eluded off
the column
very early and so the other option that
we have is something called hylic or
hydrophobic
interaction liquid interaction
chromatography which is essentially the
opposite of reverse phase where you
start with a high amount of organic
typically acidic nitrile or a
organic that's aprotic you have a very
polar stationary phase like silica
and then you increase the amount of
water uh in that
in that gradient to elute in a reverse
order so in this case the
hydrophobic species would come out
really early while the hydrophilic
species would be retained
and so you have to make this choice well
what what kind of analytes we have well
we have
very polar analytes we have phosphonates
or bisphosphonates organo
organophosphates that have
a high polarity right so we might want
to start with hylic approach and indeed
we did start with a hylic approach for
this
methodology but we found that the
reproducibility of hilic columns for
this method were
very poor and we didn't get consistent
retention times across
the performance so in the end we decided
to stick with a reverse phase approach
and try to optimize the chromatography
so that we can get the separation we
need on a on a reverse phase column and
this is an example of where we started
with
on this column using a a initial
separation
and while we can't separate everything
out at least we have a place to start
and we can then
move to optimizing the chromatography
so we did that we moved on to changing
different components within the system
and of course one of the key parts of
this is picking the right
modifiers the right mobile phases
and you can see a list of the multiple
mobile phases that were tested
in this in this approach uh katie uh
went through a very long list of
different kinds of
modifiers to see how well we could
separate these ions
partly because they're very very
hydrophilic and so separating on
c18 required uh optimizing these
approaches right so in general
you want to have a a mobile phase that
is
2 2 pka units away from your ions and
these
these ions are typically have a pka of
around 2.7 or so
or 2 to 2.3 and for the most part the
top
top five top six uh
mobile phases had a ph around two to two
point seven depending on what's measured
and so 20 millimeter ammonia acetate
with or without formic acid
uh or or even ammonium format we tried
didn't work extremely well
we then just tried using formic acid
alone and that didn't work well
and in the end what seemed to work
extremely well was using
acetic acid at 0.5 percent now acetic
acid would have a ph
about 4 or so in solution so it would
still be a very good
mobile phase for negative ionization and
so we have to play between
the separation but also ionization
efficiency and so by using
0.5 acetic acid we still get a
strong ionization efficiency as well as
separation you can see that with the red
trace and the chromatogram
uh by using 0.5 percent acetic acid in
in the mobile phase a we can get that
separation
now we can still also think about the
type of water and
surprisingly the type of water always
makes a difference no matter where you
are
and so if we look at lcms grade water
versus
millicu water i've always been the on
the assumption that buying
bottled water or lcms grade water would
be
the best approach but in this case what
we found is that milliq water was
actually
improved our sensitivity and that's the
gray the gray trace that you see in the
chromatogram where we get an improved
sensitivity
we don't really know why we get improved
sensitivity whether it's less we have
just less cations present and the
negative ion mode that might make a
difference
or or less background interference we
don't know yet but in the end milliqueue
water tend to
perform better so testing your water is
a very important part of this process
so then the sort of final step in this
is
adjusting the mobile phase for part b so
methanol versus
what mobile phase we said it has settled
on because it improved the best
sensitivity versus the cd nitrile
but we wanted to try whether a motor
modifier in that made a difference
um and in the end what we found is that
no modifier made the most difference
was sensitivity and most separation and
that's the red trace
uh you can see at the bottom where we
see we still get excellent separation
of these highly polar analytes so
remember that these are very highly
polar but we have excellent separation
across the chromatogram
and very strong sensitivity and we pull
out and tease out some of these later
eluding species without
that with just methanol and here you can
see the gradient that we employed for
this method
and in the end it tended to work fairly
well and it's a
roughly 10 minute method with about five
minutes needed for equilibration at the
end
and so a fairly fairly fast method but
and able to separate about eight
compounds within that mode
so a lot of work went into extraction
and that sort of
shrunk this down given the time that we
have the
extraction from bone was a very highly
complex approach
because it's one of the more complex
matrices partly because you have
a lot of calcium you have a lot of ions
you have a lot of other species that are
present
you have to break the bone down you have
to you have to
pulverize it and get to fine powder
which is that each bone would be
different for that and it takes an
extreme amount of force to do that
and so katie spent a good a part of a
year really trying to optimize the
extraction procedure for this
but basically what happens is we
demineralize uh
the species we wash it we add calcium
to precipitate any salts as a way to get
out other species that are present other
metabolites or other cations that are
present to get them out there then we
wash the salt out
and then we do solid phase extraction of
this material
and then in this case we're conditioning
with four mils of one percent formic
acid
in methanol and then adding hcl loading
the samples and washing
and washing it with hcl and then eluding
with one percent formic acid in methanol
and then evaporating and reconstituting
in a 0.2 ml
uh 0.5 acetic acid which is the mobile
phase that we started with so very
polar mobile phase and ideally you like
to start your separation with the same
your your analyte should be dissolved in
the same mobile phase
that you start with and in this case
that worked pretty well and so
in this in this picture you can see sort
of the separation that we get
with this type of analysis and the big
precipitate in the middle would be all
that calcium and all that
uh part part of the bone that we don't
want all that precipitate that falls out
so if we look at a chromatographic trace
of this work uh we can see
part of the reason why high resolution
was important for this i'm not showing
any mass spectra at this point
but the gray trace is citrate and
citrate levels in the bone even though
we try to precipitate
out are extremely high citrate would be
a common species that would be present
in bone
and you can sort of see it's five to ten
times greater in soft tissue
versus other
and versus bone but it still has a high
amount of
of contamination and underneath this i'm
showing the blue traces those are the
different analytes of interest so
with citrate it causes extreme amount of
ion suppression
which is not ideal for this kind of
analysis and so we want to get a we have
to sort of find another approach
another way to precipitate out that and
so uh we did find a way to precipitate
citrate
out to remove some of it and so we in
the orange trace is what was before
and now we have the grey trace which is
better still not ideal but we're
precipitating some of the
some of it out to at least help in our
detection mode before we move to real
samples
so what kind of suppression are we
observing so if we look at a sample of
0.5 nanograms per gram
of each of these analytes and 5
nanograms per gram we can
observe that we have about 80 percent
ion suppression for empa which is our
earliest diluting
compound versus about 11 ion suppression
for pmta which is our late
latest alloying diluting species so it's
generally related to evolution order and
it's generally related to
that citrate background then that that's
causing this sign of suppression now
there's
almost no way to get rid of all the
citrate without precipitating out
our ions of interest because of their
propensity to
to have the same kind of chemistry
involved in precipitation so we can only
go so far without
eliminating part of our ions so in this
case we just have to deal
with the ion suppression that's present
and
and try to move forward and do it do a
study in which we can at least
understand whether or not we can detect
from from a bone matrix
so we look at the limit of detection in
the other matrices
that have been used by lcms and the
references are listed here
from nail versus hair versus serum yarn
and bone
we can see that we have pretty wide
range where impa would be about
7 500 picograms per ml and 20
grams per mill in bone uh which is what
we're studying
and these are this is our limits of
detection that we've determined so we
generally have fairly good limits of
detection for every other analyte except
empa again that's our earliest diluting
species and it's going to have
the most ion suppression and we'll
probably have the least detectability so
at least at least we know that so if we
don't detect it we know we might be
below a certain level below 350
picograms per gram
and so that might tell us a little bit
something a little bit about the species
but
a little bit about the individual but
not everything present in this sample
so let's move on to sample analysis and
testing this method with a set of real
samples
that we were able to obtain in a through
the
u.s army collaboration and through a
study that they did and so they
had a small study in mini pigs where
they analyzed
uh they gave a dose uh at a certain
amount of weeks
uh and you can see the dose listed for
each of these animal
each each of these individual animals
either a transdermal or intramuscular
dose
was given i'll note that in in the in
the dermal cases
uh we had about six in in the dermal and
six in the intramuscular
two of those that were given a dermal
dose died overnight
uh post-exposure so they had a very
toxic effect the other ones were
euthanized and those were then samples
were collected from all of these
individuals
to try to help understand and see if we
could detect the bones from the
detect chemicals in the bone from these
different treatments
and this is an example of what the bone
would look like this is cut down into
smaller pieces and then pulverized
and then pulverized into this fine
powder and then each one of these
samples and then extracted of course
they're randomized
so that the individual that we didn't
know this up front which ones got which
we just did the extraction
and did the analysis in the background
so let's look at some of the results
and so this is uh to confirm that we
have a real method we have a negative
control always and a positive control
to know that this is what's happening
and this is an srm method now
and so looking at the quantitative srn
performance uh we can see that we can
detect
at least down to 750 picograms per gram
as our positive control within this
sample
so then if we look at the all 12 samples
together we have
in green those that are dermal and
yellow those are intramuscular
and the two in the two animals that died
overnight we get a very strong response
for empa in this sample the other ones
we have a little bit of a response but
probably not
enough to call it as a strong as a
strong detected
species um so the great thing is
is an srm method we always have
qualifier ions and quantifier ions and
so you have
on the previous slide those are these
are quantifier ions
and then we have the qualifier ions so
we get confirmation that one and six
those that died from acute exposure and
acute
response definitely were positive in
this bone matrix for what would be
present
and we can call this as as this would be
a reason why they
they would they have passed away because
it and
why these two i don't know exactly why
these two would have had this effect
could be they metabolized it faster it
could be the
exposure was was slightly different
based on that dermal
approach but we don't know but at least
we know that we can detect and confirm
that it was present
based on on those two samples
and so what we also can measure is we
can measure
the the type of bone the and we can
measure the ratio in that type of bone
and that ratio can tell us a little bit
about
the toxicity performance and or and why
toxicity would be there
there's a lot more work that needs to be
done on this to really understand what
that
ratio means if we don't
so so this is just really showing you
that you can start to do these
calculations and then maybe make an
assumption between one and six they had
a higher ratio
and so maybe that ratio sorry a lower
ratio and maybe that tells us a little
bit about toxicity
and uh two to five didn't have uh that
have a
have a slightly different ratio and so
that might give us some inclination as
to what's going on
from a biological perspective but again
more work it will need to be done to
confirm that
and you can sort of see that as i click
along the the blue versus the
red tells us that that ratio difference
is really
something that we're going to tease out
and try to think about more
ways in which we can use this
information to help understand the
biochemistry that's happening
so katie wrote an excellent
method development article about this to
show you how and
all the whole process uh that went
through and in more detail the methods
that go into this so i
encourage you to go look and look at
that method
review it and and um
ask any questions that you might have
about what happens and how you can
detect
weapons from uh chemical weapons and
nerve agents it's a very intriguing
article and the previous review article
also has a lot of information about what
might happen
if we can start to do more scale up
screening especially in places like
syria where
we had a a potential chemical attack but
we don't have any way to confirm that
if we could allow a forensic
anthropologist to go in collect a little
bit of samples we might be able to
confirm
this kind of scenario
so as a review we developed a model to
understand incorporation of toxic
substances into bone
we developed an instrument method and
sample preparation methods to go along
with that
a lot of validation went in this and you
can again review that article in
forensic toxicology to
to get all the details that went
involved we
we were in the end able to analyze
samples from minifigs exposed to nerve
agents
and found that empa was found in
multiple samples using this triple quad
approach
and this would really be represent the
first time that this kind of exposure
has ever been detected in skeletal
remains
so it represents hopefully we think as a
good future forward for analytical
chemistry and forensic toxicology and
forensic anthropology
but beyond that there's also some
interest there's also potential that
maybe this kind of analysis in bone
would be important
for understanding uh maybe cancer
therapies or other understanding
osteoporosis medications
so um it's interesting to note that in
the early 1940s
uh one of the first cancer therapies was
based off nitrogen mustard
and that's chlorambucil because it has a
similar structure
to that it was developed based on that
structure
that had developed in the 1940s and it's
been used to treat leukemia and
non-hodgkin's lymphoma for over 40 years
one of the side effects of it is bone
marrow suppression
because of this rapid cell turnover
nothing's really been measured in terms
of what happens with the bone itself
but it's possible that there could be
some some
hydration into the bone causing this
kind of change and maybe
understanding that might help us
understand efficacy
and of course fixed platinum and
carboplatin also work in a similar
similar to mustard gas
and i already talked to you about
organic phosphate pesticides so this
could be one case where we could
measure organophosphate pesticides in
death cases to try to help understand
whether or not that could have
contributed to
to the individual who passed or in
general
when you're studying maybe a new drug or
newbo a new
a drug that affects your bone maybe i'm
measuring what happens in the bone
chemistry will help us understand how
that how the efficacy of that drug is
and that just shows the structure of
koran people
so with that i'd like to acknowledge um
the tissue that we had
we actually had received a lot of donor
samples um
that was from a a company here that that
uses
bone to to help grow new new material
and so that
we were able to use that as test
subjects we had a lot of help in the
forensics labs as well as in the
clinical lab dr garganta dr chronister
dr curtis dr stickel
amanda reeves and fennel patal as well
as dr rudolf
rudolph johnson of the cdc and we also
want to thank todd myers
and kimberly whitten bradley bergen and
the us
and our icd for uh providing the samples
for this mini pig study that we're able
to
use and test our method i also want to
thank the research funding
this was funded by the university of
florida department of anthropology as
well as the
maple center for forensic medicine the
forensic sciences foundation and the
american academy of forensic sciences
and humanitarian rights resource center
i'd also like to thank agilent for
providing the seed instrument for us to
do this work
and for working with us when uh to help
think through the process of method
development
and help uh help use the technology the
right way to solve this
this important problem with that i'd
also like to thank you for your
attention and if you have any questions
i'll be happy to answer thank you
and thank you dr garrett for that
informative presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
simply click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we already have some great questions
coming in we encourage you to add some
more
dr garrett our first question from our
audience member is
you use a combination of high resolution
mass spectrometry and traditional
tandem mass spectrometry on a triple
quadruple
do you think that the high resolution
can also be used
in quantitation instead of the
traditional
triple quad
well susie thank you that's an excellent
question the triple quad is a mainstay
in the clinical lab
most instrumentation there is used for
quantitative analysis so it's not going
to go anywhere
but with the work we did i think that
high resolution mass spectrometry will
have
a strong future in the clinical world
and i think it's
for a couple reasons one the dynamic
range of high resolution instruments is
getting
wider so we're able to capture a larger
concentration range
which is very important especially in
this kind of study
sensitivity is getting much closer to
those of a triple quad the triple quad
is still the most sensitive
instrument that we have uh and and
a second reason that i think is is
really important we sort of showed this
with method development for
for contamination or for not
contamination but rather presence of
citrate
and other endogenous species that could
interfere
and when using a high resolution
platform for quantitation
patient samples are going to be highly
varied and it could give us the
opportunity to find
patient samples that fail in
quantitative methods
and we could dig into the into the high
resolution
information and find out whether a
specific type of metabolite
is causing that interference that may be
present in only a subset of patients so
it might allow us to
categorize a subset of patients that
that may
uh fail for a specific reason and help
improve the method but also help improve
our understanding of what's going on
in the extraction and going on in
analysis so i think
as high-resolution platforms
begin to be employed more and more
you'll see them transition into both
quantitative and semi-quantitative
approaches
in a clinical setting
thank you for that and we have one more
question coming in
what was the most difficult aspect in
method development for this study
yeah so that's another great question we
spent a lot of time on this study in
many different areas and i initially
thought that the chromatography would be
the most difficult part and
i sort of talked about the decision
between hylic
chromatography versus traditional
reverse phase chromatography and we had
set out to do hillock uh in the
beginning but we quickly found out that
it just wasn't
going to be as robust or reproducible
for us in this setting and so we
once we went away from that the method
of development for the chromatography
got very
more simplistic and it was really more a
matter of testing the different mobile
phases
by far the most difficult part of the
study was the extraction
uh there were the there aren't many
methods out there for extraction
of these species from bone and
even the extraction of these species
from blood can be
can be difficult at times and so and
bone presents a very unique kind of
matrix that mixes between both solid
structure meaning very difficult to
homogenize and grind
to get a a medium that you can extract
from so we had to optimize how you
pulverize the bone and different kinds
of bone
it will have different strengths so that
kind of pulverization might vary
depending on the type of bone you're
analyzing
and then we also had that had to verify
all across the
approach that the extraction from that
kind of pulverized material would be
a valid approach for doing extraction so
we spent a lot of time testing different
modes of extraction
testing different methods that would
allow us to
to know that we're detecting what's
there and then once we get to that point
and analyze real samples the idea of ion
suppression comes in
because we're looking at polar species
that are related to
those that are present in the bone like
citrate
we have to optimize the extraction to
maintain those species in the extraction
but also remove those contaminants and i
said citrate
was one of those contaminants that was
important so the addition of sodium
hydroxide in the extraction process
helped
reduce some of those salts but we could
never really fully eliminate them so we
still have to deal with the ion
suppression
even in an optimized extraction approach
and so i think
as other people start to work on this
and new methods come out maybe that'll
get better
um but hopefully we showed you that it's
even
even with the amount of ion suppression
present it's still possible to have a
very sensitive
method and valid method to analyze and
extract and confirm that these are
present
so that we can look in the future of new
studies and hopefully
gain some insight into more
human related uh interaction with this
kind of
species
dr garrett thank you for your time today
and for your important research
and before we go i want to thank the
audience members for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via
contact information you provided
at the time of your registration and
actually we
just had another question come in can we
uh give you that one too dr garrett
yes yes please here we go uh how
often did you have to clean the ms
instrument
over the course of the study that's a
two-part question
and were there any concerns about the
inorganic
organics getting into the instrument
affecting the instrument performance
yes that's an excellent question and in
in the beginning with them with the
methods that we had
we had a lot of contamination so after
during the method of element phase we
had to clean the source regularly
and um and that would be once a week or
or every couple weeks before we
were able to continue around and we'd
see a drop in signal and we'd have to
clean deeper because of that
after the optimized method uh
we and and the approaches for separation
and removal of contamination
we found that we didn't have to clean it
as often so we went down to a more
regular schedule of cleaning
once a month or once every couple months
and so the method it still was
was able to run very very robustly not
have to worry about the contamination
over that period of time
and i think obviously we can get better
at that uh of course so you can
you can as you optimize the method you
have to test that long-term stability
and it's also i think that's also
important question for anyone who's
working with the method it's important
to know when to maintain your instrument
to ensure you have the optimum
performance and
you know the use of internal standards
is a key part of that the use of
of course knowing your lower limits of
detection and having standards
in there to test your lower limit of
detection all the time so that you know
you're you're getting you know your
instrument is an optimal performance so
that when the real samples come through
you can trust that results are going to
be detected and
or you can trust the results aren't
detected too and that's another key
factor to think about so thank you for
that question
and thank you again audience members and
dr garrett thank you for this important
study and thank you to agilent for
sponsoring today's webinar
again any questions not asked to answer
today will be
um provided via contact information you
provided at the registration
the webcast can be viewed on demand
through may
2021 until next time stay safe and have
a great day
bye-bye thank you